[Music]
hello everybody welcome to these games
of the week lecture actually we're gonna
see a game that just happened today in
the grand Swiss it's this new idea from
the International Federation where
they're organizing a super tournament in
Isle of Man small island in Great
Britain and why is so important this
tournament well because the winner will
qualify for the candidates you know how
many players play in the candidates guys
14 no less eight players and then the
winner will face the world champion
Magnus Carlsen in a match right so
that's why this grants which is so
important and basically the best hundred
players in the world are competing there
and also son invited players from the
organization and some strong women so
yes
yeah Magno San Fran you are playing that
means of course they cannot qualify for
the candidates because Magnus is the
current world champion and Fabiano is
qualified because he was the last
challenger so they are playing probably
for money and he exactly is for example
if Magnus it's a good training for Jane
as well if Magnus wins the tournament or
Fabiana wins the tournament probably the
second will will well qualify for the
candidates I don't know we have to read
the regulations but probably it will
happen something like that and today
already in the first round there was a
big surprise and of course it's super
strong these tournaments so the pairings
were already too difficult for everyone
and Vishy Anand was facing with the
black pieces of Jenny Niger you know
this player Evgeny major or nature he's
a strong run master from Russia I think
he even won the European Championship
once the European Championship is
extremely strong and BC Anna lost today
in a brilliant game full of tactics so
let's just try to understand what
happened in the 64 squares in that
beautiful game so d4 was played by AB
Janine Niger native six c4 e6
so this is very used in the elite right
because they want to go for the
nimzo-indian after Knight c3 so there
are many different ways of avoiding the
names of India with white if you want to
try maybe g3 intending to go for the
Catalan or maybe 93 and of course has
sorry black has many many alternatives
here satisfy so you can go b6 going for
the Queen's Indian we should be for the
bow go India c5 going for D Benoni d5
going for the Queens gambit and but
alright in the game
Nagi went for Knight c3 Bishop b4 the
nimzo-indian one of the most solid
defenses in chess so basically black is
developing a piece now he's ready to go
sure castle and in many positions black
would take this knight on c3 ruining
white construction in return of course
white will get the bishop pair which is
very important in chess there are many
different approaches here for why do you
know any
how can you play against Bishop b4 Queen
c2 is one of them
the idea is to recapture on c3 with the
Queen not to ruin your pawn structure
Bishop d2 F 3 is one of the sharpest
lines in the nihms oh you want to go if
or in the next move so after f3 the
people play C 55 on b5 and this is
completely crazy
a3 it's also possible what else
normal moves Knight f3 and III Bishop g5
this is of course possible to pin in the
knight on f6 and has happen in the game
III which normally leads to positions
where white would love to develop the
Bishop to d3 or even 93 - this is a
really interesting idea with black with
the white pieces cuz after 92 e2 you
wanna kick this Bishop from before and
if black team decides to take on c3 you
will be able to recapture with your
knife not
your pawn structure so here Vishy Anand
the Tiger of Madras this is how he is
well known you know why
Tiger of Madras yeah you are in your
Indian yes oh oh you were you were born
in India so what is Madras you can tell
us Chennai right this is the the way the
people use to call Chennai the the city
where this Yemen was born which
pyromania are you from
noth-nothing part okay cool so III and
then short castle from BC Anand and now
Bishop d2 this is not the main line the
main line by far our Bishop d3 or 9282
but Bishop d2 the idea is rather simple
you want to recapture and c3 with the
bishop so it's pretty natural right
d5 by DeShannon 93 and b6 one of the
main problems our dispositions for black
is this bishop on CA it's not enjoying
good diagonals right so that's why you
cannot develop by a dis diagonal so
that's why you have to give a square for
this bishop and then to place it on b7
and then this iron I could get opened
and actually the bishop would be quite a
nice place to be 7 so b6 route c1 now
you're looking with x-rays to this c7
put in many positions you wanna trade on
d5 and then there could be some 95 ideas
so Bishop b7 65 and now how would you
recapture on d5 with the pot who would
recapture with the bishop nobody with
the knight or with a pawn pawn Knight
okay with the pony's more natural why
because you control the e4 square if you
capture here with a piece which is also
possible then white would be able to
push the central pawns at some point and
then will gain a lot of space right so
that's why normally black cakes with a
pot which controls efore which is a
really natural square an important
square
so ETA XD 5 and now how would you
develop your f1 Bishop to e2 to b5 to c4
to d3 or a 6 give me 1 squared d3 this
is the most active Square right because
you are targeting also the 87 point so
Bishop d3 the most natural move here and
Bishop e7 what do you think about this
move Bishop e7 from BC Annan exactly so
you got two plants here mainly at some
point you would love to go 94 but then
of course after Knight takes e4 now
black is in real trouble because the
bishop is hanging and you also would
like to play C fine but then after a
three you will be forced to capture this
knight on c3 right so that's why Bishop
e7 is a good move you are intended to go
maybe c5 in the future and you won't
lose the bishop pair so here sure castle
by Niger Knight B to d7 developing a
piece and now Knight e5 what do you
think is White's plan in the next moves
if you do nothing with the black pieces
for example if I play something passive
like c64 exactly you want to push a four
reinforce the center and then maybe
plans like Queen f3 Queen h3 and then
start tacking on the King inside there
even plants with g4 g5 and then this
could get really really really messy for
black so that's why after ninety five
black to economy 5 if you wait one more
tempo let's say what c6 is f4 now white
would take with the F pawn and then this
file will get open for the rook and then
there are so many attacking ideas
related by bringing the Queen to the key
inside so that's why after Knight e5
Knight takes d5 was played by BC and 95
and 97 attacking ePHI there's only one
good move here for white so what do we
play
would you play Queen h5 you have to
decide if you play Queen h5 or f4 what's
wrong with efore you're gonna tell me
you can take any file you can play d4
and then take on e5 right so what's the
best move Queen to h5 or f4 you like a
four pipe why you are refusing Queen
rejecting sorry Queen h5 g six and then
you lose upon so Queen h5 is not a good
move because of the g6 you have to move
the Queen and then this pawn is under
attack right so Queen h5 a bad move but
instead we push the f1 and now black
plays Knight c5 really natural move
attacking this Bishop and then you want
to open this diagonal for this bishop
right so be she is playing quite
interestingly and Bishop b1 to keep the
be sure targeting the h7 pawn and now B
she went for d4 and now it's a really
important moment for white what would
you play here you drive the white pieces
yes yeah
Knight to e4 then boom a free night for
me and I love free nights they are so
tasty right so 94 we can't go there so
what do we play
yeah 95 is the best booth by firing the
position the thing is if you take on v4
then black is extremely active after
Queen takes e14 each one and for example
rook 8d - sorry d8 all black pieces are
coordinating extremely well look at this
guy here is fantastic bishop yeah it's
the king of the disco right this this
Bishop on b7 and then the you're putting
pressure on d2 and black is perfectly
fine so that's why after d4 Knight b5
was played and this is another crucial
moment for this Janna he has to decide
what to do what the deep one with the
deep one sorry so what do we do put or
take push your tape push your tape three
seconds in the clock three two one all
right so the best move is d3 but this is
getting so complicated and think we are
gonna try to explain why because if you
take on e3 and then you wanna trade on
d1 people who are start who start to
play chess beginners they whenever they
can take something they'll take it right
whenever I play with my father's own
game he'll take everything possible in
the chessboard but if you do that in
this position after context he 3 Bishop
takes and now Queen d1 rook takes e1
this position is so good for why because
you are targeting c7 before is coming
you have the rook on the D file on on
the C file and probably black is
completely lost so that's why black has
pushed upon 2 D 3
but then this pawn is blocking this
bishop but also could could be a witness
right what would you play here with
white before it's an option definitely
but I guess I have different
alternatives here one of them is Queen
d5 be careful
ruk f3 and then I could go 984 and and
the ponen on c7 is hanging right very
interesting this move before let's try
to think all together so so so so for
example if I play 94 you wanna take on
c7 rook c8 might be 592 Queen takes 25
hi double attack 9 to be 594 ah yes true
and then this is protected 94 at least I
speech before yeah
so what nature played was 94 which is
very natural now you want to go before
right and then you want to take this
phone on D 3 so let's play
prophylactically how do we stop before
a5 right
a5 we stop before then we secure this
square for the knight on c5 right so at
this moment nature went for Queen to g4
really natural move bringing the Queen
to the action may be threatening 9f5
attacking in 7 attack in g7 and that's
why nature played g6 exactly sorry
you want to go B 383 if before it's too
slow I would say it's too slow so black
can do a lot of things here and oh maybe
even have 6 at some point but 24 is a
more direct approach so you wanna just
stack so g6 was played and now f5 by
nature so what's the threat now what are
we threatening f6 winning a piece so how
do we play here with the black pieces
f6 f6 looks really really dangerous f6
because I just take on g6 right h5 looks
whoof really dangerous to rook e8 that's
a really natural move because do you
wanna play Bishop f8 after f6 but then
there is this move a six and then we are
blowing up jockey inside right if you
take me six then F takes G six and
you'll have to resign pretty soon right
so the base move according to the engine
was Queen d5 and I played 94 which is
also very natural because you give the
c5 square for the bishop and then you
attack the d2 Bishop right but okay
Queen d5 was the best move not windy for
don't blunder like me but 25 because if
you now go f6 you can go age five and
then you have to keep an eye on this g2
pawn you go Queen g5 then there could be
94 and you go Queen eight six nine f6
and then you attack d2 with the
checkmate
anyway after de sixth is a real mess but
bishop played maybe the most natural
move 94 now f6 is nothing and then
you're attacking this d2 Bishop so what
do we play here with the white pieces
nature decide to play in a extremely
aggressive way
what do you want to go f6 all right
f6 is an interesting move what else
this would be one guys up there in
YouTube I also have your chat here so
you wanna answer any of the questions
you are welcome to do it yeah
Bishop d3 this is where actually major
did he sacrificed the whole piece and
then took on g6 exactly so look at this
variation Bishop d3 Knight takes D 2 and
now F takes G 6 looks pretty good for
white but then again we have to find
something to breed and I'm gonna ask you
what do you do if I just take another
piece not except one
hi now what you want to take on eight
seven or an f7 e six teen f2 no right
this is a really terrible move because I
will go teenage shades and then what do
you want to do now at a five and Bishop
g5 boom H four okay I can't even play
Bishop c8 now you should see eight and
take on f5 right I can't even take on e3
with a check not so sure about that but
definitely I can play Bishop CA and
black sweater so be careful there is a
really beautiful combination now after
night xf1 what do you play guys Daniel
Daniel Sanchez saw it
let's see you find the continuation that
Daniel Sanchez one of the users from the
YouTube channel saw
take some time salmon I think I can just
go again to h8 Queen a5 that's good that
was good man
I can take care Quinn f7 and then Queen
g8 threatening checkmate on g2 yeah okay
but this is not it's much better for
white but it's not winning and I think I
can even have something else too for
example Quinta except 7 and then Brooke
f1 right
probably this is also good but this
language King h8 is not decisive yet g7
you want to go g7 this looks good too I
have to say but then I could maybe go 93
Queen h5 okay the most the simplest way
to play here is either Queen 85 or
knight c6 look at this mod 96 extremely
beautiful so if you take now on d3 that
is T takes at 7 and then no matter what
Queen g7 checkmate and then you take the
knight then Queen h5 and then nobody
will stop me from going Queen 87 in the
next move right you take on g6 then
there is Bishop d6 + 27 checkmate
okay you can go rook F 7 here but after
taking there gonna be a lot of lots of
checks and then probably black will have
to resign so that's why BC Anna didn't
take on FY but instead he took on g6 and
then
we have to go all in now we should go
all in boom [ __ ] of g6
and now B she went for King h8 but I'm
gonna ask you guys how do you win this
game after H takes g6 ah you fell for
the trap my friend
you see even then it is sloughing 96 not
the best move so why why not these are
defensive resource here for Black Knight
what not a three-drug takes F 3 you
resign
no there's made on g7 in the next mood
you've got to do something about that
Bishop f6 Bishop f6 rook f6 it's not
working hello so come on guys you can
find it for C moves we need six you
wanna move we need six with the black
pieces
it's a Superman youth we need Superman
can jump whatever you wanna look at five
somebody is saying no it's simpler it's
easier than that we just have to cover
the g7 square we can do it in two moves
root D hate Queen eight six checkmate
yes
rook F watt rook F what no Brooke f6 no
roof yes and then exactly I'm black
better be careful
rook f1 ruk f1 and Queen g8 yeah because
I mean 96 was a bad move but instead
after keen h8 so let's change the order
or let's not allow Queen g8 so how do we
do this
Queen 86 King g8 and now 96
there's no 28 okay so Rukh f1 rook F 1
and then there's no quintet then next
move Queen to g7 checkmate okay awesome
so after F takes Bishop takes Bishop
late King h8 a good defensive move and
then we have to go all in again all in
exactly Bishop 8 7 so beautiful this
game from major
it's what it works it's a good it's a
good line he should have gone like as we
said Queen d5 but okay this is still
very very messy I mean a lot of things
happen in the game and we're gonna see a
lot of mistakes so Bishop eight seven
and now if you play Knight f1 in the
game bc2 Khan f1 with a check you take
with the night then queen h5 and then
again Bishop d6 followed by Queen eight
seven and then you go kingi 796 so Rukh
f1 rook f1 and now white thread is very
very simple
of course you can never take on x7
because there's rook f7 and Queen g7 so
our our threat with the white pieces is
to go queen h5 can you find a defense
now can you play a prophylactic move
against Queen h5
Queeny eight okay Queenie eight but then
after Queenie eight
oh sorry Queenie eight you play Bishop
g6 first and then Queen h5 is coming
right so no there is one good move here
for black let's see if you guys find it
guys in the YouTube channel then cut up
at an edge can you find it my friend
Queen d5 it's very very interesting but
I guess I can just go I can go here let
me think
even Bishop - ah you are threatening to
go Queen G - right very very interesting
move be for Queen takes d4 check Queen
g5 I didn't think about this move this
is really interesting so what do we play
here with white there has to be a way
for sure not a three doesn't look like
the best move right so let's think all
together
boom boom boom boom boom boom no no no B
should be for Queen a for Queen eight
five twenty eight seven and black wins
so how do we solve it
maybe Luke f3 Knight takes a three with
a check it's not working neither three I
think you um you can take it
rook takes Queen d1 am Bishop f3 right I
was thinking about this move
rogue f2
okay fritz is not gonna tell oh did I do
something strange I click sorry okay
yeah yeah okay here right here okay now
it's alright
25 really interesting so we have to find
a way for white here Queen a3 Queen G to
check Queen takes Bishop takes King
takes ah this could be yeah because now
the eight seven Bishop is not hanging
because they struck f7 yes you can take
an f1 of course so Queen d5 let's think
guys
queen bee farm that was a really nice
suggestion ruk f7 and then if I print
xe2 again okay
with the xf7 that's right so that's not
a solution
and why you guys didn't you like my
suggestion look after
so why not Luke F - looks good right you
want to take the bishop now and then
I'll go queen age five anywhere
are you sure anywhere because if you
yeah King g8 and now let's say Queen g6
King h8 and then night two is six and
looks winning for white right so maybe
rook F 2 was was was good or even Brooke
f4 I was thinking now because if you
take on g2 Queen takes bishop takes this
is the same line that we were checking
before but the root remember was on f1
and then you wanted to take on f1 and
you take on 87 blue kept silent followed
by rookie 70 should be good enough right
okay but Queen d5 really interesting
move any other moves so busy on and
plate Bishop g5 very tricky because now
what happens if we play Queen x5 Queen
h5 s actually a bad move Bishop yeah
Anna King h1 yeah kingi - the thing is
if we go Queen h5 straight away we
should be three keen h1 queen g5
straight away so there's no discover
move and then you are threatening
checkmate on g2 and also the knight on
d4 so basically black would be winning
right so that's why after this of g5
nature went Knight to f5 which is
defending the e3 pawn and then one
question can we take this bishop on the
h7 now it's mating three how we need
five kg a 26 and then Queen d7 right and
if you go to f8 what do we play here
there are many ways of winning the game
now but fine 196 nice move now whatever
you do there is Queen f7 checkmate
so after night f5b Shannon was sorry
played Queen d3 threatening checkmate
with went to f1 so rook e1 was played
and now B she played Bishop e3 check
beautiful move because you can take with
the night because there is Queen 87
coming back and protecting everything
you can take with the rogue because
there's Queen f1 so white is forced to
go king h1 in this position and now and
now sorry try to find defense for for
black here how do you play this Queen g7
coming right
Queen d7 that's a possibility I guess
Queen d7 is just losing after something
like hmm
Bishop g6 for example you know to go
queen h5 right there is other
possibility here for black to cover the
g7 square
so how how do we cover g7 there's only
exactly Bishop 86 very beautiful because
now we can take in this bishop because
there's queen exam and it looks like
vision and is surviving but actually
nature played one of the best games in
his life here he made a mistake though
the best move was Bishop d6 sorry in
order to go Queen age five or Queen age
four but he went for Queen g6 which
looks almost crushing right because we
are threatening made in one two three
for example if I just I don't know if I
if I sorry Ruby eight yeah so how do we
win now
ex-exactly queen of 1687 queen eight-six
kindy 827 checkmate
so be she found a nice resource again
okay exactly so this is the resource
that we she found Bishop g2 suddenly the
position is not that clear we have to
figure out why in the game nature took
with the kid apparently was a bit better
to take with the queen and now it looks
like black can take on eighty seven if
you take on a eight days Queen f5 so
white has to take on eight six and now
what would you play here with white what
sorry with black
Queen a3 is a possibility if you take on
h6 then there is queen a 8 so apparently
the engine says that Knight f3 and the
position is around equal this is just a
complete mess
right but in their game
wipe took with a kin
and what do we play now I mean white is
checkmate it has with Queen f6 you want
to play rook f8 do you want to play
Queen f3 you want to play Queen d5 Queen
f3 but then all right yes exactly after
Queen f3 King G Y and then what do we
play
Ruka fate you want to go for rook f8 and
then I'm going to ask you what do you
play if I just take your little tasty
bishop you resign already are you sure
why not 24 probably I can go 93 neither
three check King h1 and Queen g7 is it
that clear this position so I can take
here and now it's not clear at all yeah
so what did we miss
so Queen f3 you want to go rook f8 here
and then let's think again
can I go just night at six Queen f2 and
then you you bit me yeah so how about if
I just take again this guy and then you
said queen g4 right very very
interesting
now I see the point
so 93 93 and how about this move crazy
now g5 boom so when the floor I go oh
sorry not this one
I keep insisting in blundering my queen
all the time so King G 2 Queen d2 I just
take the Queen right and then I earn a
PSI Knight g1 mate II won and then I
wanted to go this move here but then you
got Queen d7 exactly so Queen d7 Bishop
f5 wins is this waiting I think so yeah
I think king of two is a good move here
you go to g7 then I can just take and at
the very least I can I can go back with
my bishop at the very least and then I
got two pieces and upon up which should
be completely winded right so
so Bishop g2 sorry Kim takes it to Queen
f3 was the best move in the position but
then we have to find out why Kinki one
so try to try to survive here
don't let BC on and down he needs our
support
Queen 83 Wow Wow
Queen a3 looks good actually
even queen of 1687 teenage shape you you
want to go for the perpetual now after
all these yeah that's true
so how about if I just take this guy in
86 what do you want to do neither three
and then key enough to you want to take
sorry take the route I sure checkmating
women take an h2 keen f3 I got so many
pieces now this looks so good night f7
it's coming in the next move
so this is losing right so let's go back
until here you were doing fine with
Queen f3 but now we have to find the
best move for black here
Knight e4 interesting alright very very
very interesting so hmm
94 hmm so after Queen 86 when F 2 and
Queenie one right so I have to do
something about that I was thinking
about taking on e4 Queen takes e4
what
that's a possibility okay 94 is a really
nice attempt that's not the move either
but let's try to understand why yeah
so you were thinking about nine eight
six mmm queen f2 and here Queenie 1kg -
Queen F - King 83 Queen f3 teammate for
sorry when I forgot Knight g4 right but
I think you can go to F - yeah and
should be more than okay for black here
so this is not the reason for sure
so Knight e4 I like it rookie for on
Queenie for we have sixteen eight seven
that's right that's a solution rookie
for Queenie for and Queen f6 takes takes
and checkmate - g7 great okay so no 94
one more try for black
yeah I mean it's clear we have to
protect at least 86 yeah and you try to
Queen a tree or at least you have to
Queen f4 that's a move
what's it different let's try to
understand that so now what how do you
want to take on 86 with the night I
guess and then I can go native three and
the difference is that you can't go to
the f5 right right yeah 9h for you go to
F 2 or F 1 that is 984 and then you go
to H 1 there is Queen H 2 so that's why
same stuff happens if you go to G 2
there is this fork on H 4 so this is
lost so basically after Queen afford the
only move is Queen 86 and now how do we
survive with the black pieces Knight f3
King f2 and now Queen eight six nine
eight six
marijuana God Bishop c4 really nice move
so you're saying that you want to take
here Knight takes 91 and I guess I can
play Bishop c4 dropping your knife
beautiful you want to take this guy then
you're just too many pawns down
well I mean one pawn down but it's
passed and then it's gonna be there's
gonna be enough of white to win so no
it's not Queen eight six incredible
incredibly it's not Queen eight six the
best move here the best movies Knight
takes a one so Queen takes 93 King III
takes takes takes and the engine says
that this position is around equal who
knows in practice yeah I can block them
with white I can blunder with black PCB
of course but this was the only
salvation that Bishamon had and sorry no
he went here Queen d5 which is a blunder
because of what
probably they were in tiny trouble I
don't know because I didn't check the
game lag today so so where do we go now
yeah whoa sorry so so I mean in the game
major went teenage three and then B she
went Queen D 3 and after teenage for
Hillary sang let's try to understand why
you wanted to go Queen f3 here right I
guess I guess I can just go to F for 284
sorry Queen f4 just keen age 5 and this
is just waiting for white and how about
here let's say I go for Knight f3 teen
age 5 and then I take C 1 how do you
beat me
Queen f6 same idea all the time right
here now queen 8 6 q g8 Queen to g7
there's no let's try to see if there is
something here for black after Queen f3
keen h4 I don't see anything basically
you guys find a solution here Queen f2
maybe yeah but there's Queen h2 I see it
now
so Queen f2 King h5 Queen H 298 for its
this women I don't I have no idea let's
try to understand this I don't know why
he won Queen d3 here which is clear that
he's completely lost but after Queen
Ezreal
is it that clear
teenage for and now queen queen f2
sorry Queen f3 right yeah and now if I
go back to g3 with my knight
it's not clear at all right I'm not
threatening anything with the wire with
the white pieces I can't just go Queen
f8 for example it's not clear so the
move has to be teenage for Queen f2 and
now 93
93 take the rook and queen eight six
nine a three and then I'll go I'll go
teenage five Queenie five Bishop f5 King
g8 and still not clear teenage three
that's better that's right yes and queen
f one night xf 1 yeah 95 check can a
tree sorry
Knight g5 check you can even go King g4
here
Knight x87 exactly so here takes not
clear at all not clear at all when
yeah Queen f3 definitely a better try
here for sure maybe it's still you are
still winning after night g3 probably
this is winning yeah because you have no
checks we are balancing material if you
have to go something like Queen FA this
is extremely passive and now you could
even go near f5 yeah this could be the
key
so nice g3 just can't move protecting
everything there are no more checks and
then we are balancing material and your
kin is much more unsafe so I just what
do you do here I mean I'm just taking on
86 now so you gotta go back probably to
a fete and now Knight f5 right and then
this looks completely winning for white
you can even try to go in the next move
I mean I don't know what you're doing
because I'm just taking this guy here
you go to f4
I could even try to go Queen h5 now and
there's Bishop d6 common rope she won't
call me everything's coming here right
okay so this was the game played by
nature and BC Anand as you guys saw it
was a fantastic attacking masterpiece
from the Russian player it's not usual
to see ABC Anna losing in the first
round of a Swiss of a sari of an open
tournament
this tournament is going to be extremely
interesting aside as I told you the
winner qualifies for the candidates
calcine play Fabiano Caruana
and playing the best hundred players in
the world are competing there so
probably the next week in the next games
of the week lecture will show another
game from this tournament so thank you
for coming and see you next time
[Music]
you